well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Tuesday May 28th 29th
Keane sessions and our series on
entrepreneurship and asian-type
industries
I'm Richard - arriving at the u.s. Asian
Technology Management Center at Stanford
and for those of you who are regulars or
have been here before know this series
is available to Stanford students for
university credit but it's also open to
the public and today for the last
session in our series for 2019 I'm
really happy that we have a special kind
of keynote session with mr. ping on who
is the co-founder and Managing Partner
of monkshood ventures which is a
southeast asia based technology venture
capital fund before I get further into
pings introduction and into the content
of the session administrative items for
all students please note that the
deadline for submission of all comments
and all materials is when statements
that might not on mine shows my son
okay anyway the deadline for submission
of all materials is Wednesday June 12 by
6:30 in the evening that's the end of
the scheduled exam time for the course
and since grades for graduating students
are due the following day at noon I
don't have a whole lot of extra time so
don't be late if you're not graduating
and you think you might need extra time
to finish up the materials the
activities for the course let me know
and I can give you an incomplete but
you're really supposed to let me know by
the last day of class the last scheduled
day of class is next Tuesday but we're
not doing a session next Tuesday so
whatever you can let me know as I
mentioned I'm very happy that ping can
be with us today and this session is
really a special session that's done in
cooperation with monk soul ventures for
those of you who are here and can stay
around after the end of the session we
have a more upscale version of our
refreshments after the seminar is over
and thanks to monk monk soul for that
also thanks to monk's Hill for
co-marketing
and everybody thanks for signing up and
you know putting a name tag on so that
we can all talk to each other afterward
so to talk about Southeast Asia I really
couldn't find anyone more appropriate
than ping ping is an entrepreneur who
invests in entrepreneurs I'd like to
claim that for myself that that's
actually how your body was written so
before founding monk soul ventures in
2013 he was with GSR ventures in Beijing
and was doing venture capital work in
Beijing for three years from 2010 to
2013 he is a serial entrepreneur he was
co-founder this is moving kind of
back upstream for the 1990s of a company
called electric classifieds which is
probably best known as the parent
company of match.com Peng was also
founder and CEO of a company that with
public on NASDAQ and grew to a ten
billion dollar market cap before being
acquired by HP and yet a third company
that was acquired by IBM on enterprise
identity management Pig is also very
involved with a number of nonprofit
ventures and nonprofit activities such
as solve education and yeah we're
delighted to have you come and talk to
us about the situation in Southeast Asia
before we get into what you see in
Southeast Asia right now expand a little
bit on your story what are the point of
the threads that link these things why
did you move over from entrepreneurship
to investing and then why from you know
Beijing to Southeast Asia okay I was
like sick so yeah basically that was it
doesn't matter how fun it is you can't
breathe life is not too fun so so I
decided to move and also that that was a
push but there was a pool
I was helping on the government in
Singapore with a lot of economic
development in the Technic startup scene
and I realized there was time for
seriously investing to start happening
yeah you are out actually on the border
advising the number of companies in your
role as a VC right I think was one you
know that was yes before I became a
full-time key CEOs on a board of
Tsingtao for about four or five years
okay okay so other than the air what
made you choose Southeast Asia
I am from Singapore okay I grew up in
Southeast Asia
so that's home to me Oh
and I know it reasonably well so how
would you describe Southeast Asia
overall on a Singapore is certainly a
financial center but where do you see
the activities of entrepreneurship it's
it's actually very interesting if you if
you look at the aggregate number of
Southeast Asia GDP and GDP growth over
the last 20-30 years we've been one of
the most stable growing spots in the
world anywhere from three to five
percent every year year over year and
it's because I think it's because when
naturally diversify number of countries
in Asia being largest about 250 million
people Philippines 100 million Thailand
more 18 there about 19 million so this
big chunks of humanity but it's not in
one place yes in several countries so
Indonesia might have a hiccup but
Thailand might be doing fine and vice
versa etc no there's some level
stability in that mix now in that
diversity you also have very different
political systems and very different
cultures is it really appropriate to
talk about Southeast Asia as one region
yeah that's a good question and that was
a question many people asking when we
are setting up the fund and I was asking
myself that too that was one of the
questions that I think over the last
five years has been answered because
there are literally dozens and dozens of
companies they run across these six
major countries it's not easy it's there
is a cost associated to having to know a
company culture that can handle you know
five six different countries legal
systems languages etc but it can be done
so I'm going to get you into trouble
some grab was singapore-based and they
internationalized across the region
really early yes
where I was go Jack being underneath
based really stayed in the Indonesia
market for much longer and only very
recently opened business and other
Southeast Asian countries can you
compare the two sure and I know both the
founders that nice folks very aggressive
folks but actually grep started off in
kale okay
Anthony's Malaysian I think unless he
switched recently but so the difference
is in this strategies right yeah grandpa
have already been around for a while and
then when Nadine started cranking up
Kojak he thought his strategy would be
to get really really strong in Indonesia
in his home country so that he has at
least a stronghold
Johnny and I think that's a reasonable
strategy and it's worked out pretty well
he's very strong in Indonesia you know
and then grab strong elsewhere and
that's the battle I just realized let's
do a quick audience take and ask how
many people know grab and go Jack
already ok ok so it's not like I have to
we have to explain what they do ride
hailing plus you know fan tech services
and lots of other different kind of
services yeah ok so the kind of my
uncertainty because I'm pretty sure
they're the crab's registered in
Singapore yeah but it's registered in
various other holding company I think
it's Cayman Island yeah ok but that's
kind of where I was going with this yeah
are you seeing a lot of companies that
really are based that do the investment
in Singapore but I actually set up yeah
the legal systems unfortunately in a lot
of countries not as not very conducive
for international investments and all
this so over time it's evolved to be and
this is not tecna's than this this is
way before thanks yeah Singapore is sort
of like the headquarters oh it could be
Hong Kong
these days is morally Singapore Oh Kim
an island yeah and then the other the
other countries are subsidiaries holding
company yeah but that doesn't tell you
where the business is right you know
look at the teams and where they are in
the ground etc so this is what we get
into what what is the kind of emerging
dynamics across the region in regard to
business opportunities or in regard to
you know market development yeah so so I
mentioned the word technification to you
yeah this is right before the session
let's put it on tape
yeah and I think this is one of the
easiest way to understand what's going
on Southeast Asia is about three
trillion dollars in GDP approximately
half of it is in services it's about 41%
in Indonesia to about 70% in Singapore I
think it's about 80% here in the US but
it's moving it's all of it as its
emerging it's moving towards services
right so services is growing as a larger
fraction of the GDP over time 1.3 1.5
trillion dollars and services and almost
all of it is various imaging market so
almost all of it is very very very
inefficient to give you an example every
hundred bucks you spend on Amazon 3 3
bucks goes they're shipping this stuff
around to get to get it to you that's
here this last year these in sabi sands
about 30 bucks wow there's a tenth of
the productivity in logistics not all of
it can be accountable accounted for by
the bad infrastructure a lot of it is
just a lack of information systems yeah
so yeah go ahead I was going to give you
another example lending right that's
about 250 billion of gray market lending
every year and that's where half a
percent of interest rates per
the per day there's a hundred and fifty
percent also a year is considered okay
Wow right
that's inefficiency there's not enough
information on credit worthiness etc
okay so of course that also overlaps
with large numbers of people who are
still unbanked
yeah the banking infrastructure has a
cost structure that causes you know more
than 50 percent of some countries to be
on in fact in Southeast Asia by the way
if you're interested in that India has
done something very interesting with the
national identity system that caused a
lot more people to get on the banking
system because they get on welfare
through this identity system okay but
going back to Southeast Asia the lot of
these systems are really really
antiquated really inefficient and what
the tech guys are doing is they're
coming in one vertical at a time and
mind you these are not small verticals
the larger ones are in the hundreds of
billions the smaller ones um maybe 1/2
billion you know a lot of them north of
10 billion they're going one by one into
these verticals and yeah Tecna fiying
right they're introducing technology etc
optimizing the different aspects of the
business let me give you an example so
it's not just theoretical in a company I
am in the process of investing is a
headhunting company they have average
headhunter they have has a productivity
of 2x that of outside the company right
so they're twice the productivity per
headhunter of their competitors and
they're using AI extra systems etc to
improve that productivity over time so
so just to get even more in the details
if I gave you my headhunter a database
over a hundred of let's say 10,000
engineers
and your client wants two engineers to
be based off of Jakarta right I mean
some district in Jakarta and I see this
SCB we need district in Jakarta manually
if you were to try and find these two
engine two candidates for the client
it's gonna be really hard right but
imagine if you had the linked in the
information of the hiring manager the
the Facebook profile the hiring manager
and all that data on your 10,000
candidates right then you run a Big Data
optimization search how well could you
do with the placements right much better
right so that's what's happening
vertical by vertical over across the
entire services sector in Southeast Asia
and you can see in retail for example
the e-commerce companies there's several
unicorns there that's about 10 to 12
unicorns depending on how you measure it
in Southeast Asia and a couple of them
more than a couple of them are the
e-commerce companies and transportation
there are two ten billion dollar
companies in Southeast Asia they're both
in the transportation plus plus
businesses you know logistics it is
still time to create companies there
they are you know one of our in
companies in Japan is I'm trying to
figure out what I can see in public in a
way I cannot it's doing really well they
involve more than ten thousand people
they deliver you know hundreds of
thousands of parcels of need it's a four
year old company how about this it's a
four year old company and it's about ten
times bigger than Singapore the
Singapore postal system so you know it's
interesting when you talk about
infrastructure most people when you
think infrastructure you think roads and
you think energy grid and that kind of
thing but you're talking about the
infrastructure for services there was
and that opens up all of these verticals
like retail where you don't usually
think of retailers kind of an
infrastructure business but if you've
got the backend system and to know your
customer kind of system certainly
there's a lot of opportunity there yeah
but that requires a certain amount of
technical expertise in order to pull off
how is that in the region ah so so
that's the other piece of learning we
had one of our concerns that there are
probably three places in the world where
you can build a large engine ranking
like five hundred thousand people that
engineers that's here that's China as
India
it's almost nowhere else in the world
you can do that because you can't get
them any engineers in the country and so
we thought that might be a problem for
Southeast Asia turns out that no it's
not a problem because you can't build
engineering teams anywhere in the world
now right in fact if you know anything
they're working remotely yeah okay you
need a few on the ground so they
understand the problems but you know you
can have them in in Ho Chi Minh City the
app well it used to be the app that
allows you to order Blue Book taxi and
Jakarta was built in Ho Chi Minh City so
it's very porous now mm-hmm
I've got a team in Lisbon in one of my
company because that's why the AI guy
was can you just go with the town
we've got people is Eastern Europe in
India of course yeah go jack has the
bulk of his engineers in Bangalore grab
I think it's in Vietnam is in Seattle
it's in so this is another way of
looking at their region as being
regional not just country by country but
what about the different kind of things
you have to do for different markets and
different regulatory environments I
think the company that first did this at
scale to be very localized but yet
global is okay if you
get over stack its I think about 70%
global standard stuff the maps and
navigation and pricing models etc and
then about 30 percent is very very local
they can customize all kinds of stuff so
so I think a lot of us learn from that
okay and us being kind of in the
southeast IVC yeah okay so do you see
robust
early adopter markets or how does this
work cause a lot of this infrastructure
business is going to be
business-to-business right literally
it's B to B to C but you have to get to
existing businesses - Tecna fie yeah
how is that a challenge okay let me take
one example there there's a company we
invested in called stock oh it's sort of
the equivalent of me chai in in China
how many of you know me chai okay two
three it's about a five billion dollar
company it's about six years old
it sells vegetables and eggs and produce
and stuff like that the food supply
chain in China is not very efficient so
these guys came in and they technophile
and taco is doing the same thing and
they go to the to the war room and poço
a war room is a it's like a neighborhood
canteen taco is a small provision shop
and they they tell the owners right you
have to wake up at 3 a.m. in the morning
to go get your provisions from your
marketplace instead of doing that why
don't you place your order here on this
app and I won't deliver at 7 a.m. or
whenever you open ok for the same price
ok so you can choose to wake up at 3
a.m. or you can choose to you know wake
up at 6:30 so for the same price is a
key though yeah that's hard to pull off
right um it's not because the
Longinus okay and so we initially make a
little bit less margins to get access to
the transactions okay but after after a
while and this model has been played on
the muh I in China and another company
called ninja card in India in fact Excel
India is an investor - we let the deal
with them and then with a company
constant fine yeah in in China which is
Bob she's fine so so they will meet chai
investors and ninja card investors so
they knew the model would work for they
invested in stock oh okay so that gives
you an example of why the locals would
technophile they they're not magnifying
they're just you know getting a more
convenient and sometimes more efficient
life you know okay okay
for them they see the results yes you
know the technology is how you get it so
people who know me know that I tend to
think of three major areas for an
innovation system the people the capital
and the knowledge itself so with regard
to the people to not to get too far away
from that yet we talked a little bit
about technical talent what about the
entrepreneurial knowledge and skills do
you have a lot more sophistication now
and where is that coming from
yeah so the nice thing about Southeast
Asia is that throughout our history
we've been used to a lot of different
people from all around the world
building parts of us in Singapore a lot
of the buildings and roads and Singapore
were built by P Japanese and the Koreans
and now the Chinese right and that's
true across Southeast Asia and
manufacturing came from you know other
places you know there are approximately
in Singapore ten one at 10,000 MNCs
headquartered in there okay right yeah
that's a lot of different
different parts of the world slowly used
to death and as a result it's a
comfortable place for a lot of people
from all over the place a few years ago
point people asked me where the arch
burns coming from in in Southeast Asia I
was sort of half joking Europe there
were lots of Europeans coming over you
know and partly because yeah partly
because there's lots of opportunities
and it's reasonably comfortable to come
from Europe and do business in Southeast
Asia okay the this really is a trend
then it's we have an advantage over
let's say China where almost anyone can
go to Southeast Asia and if you're
wanting to work in how hard enough to
build the relationships and to do
cross-border you know teams and all that
you can build a company okay so I don't
know you know I guess it's a trend you
know it's the nature of Southeast Asia
so in terms of the quality of the
business ideas then are you seeing more
sophisticated ideas or is it still kind
of basic things that are similar to
ideas that might have already occurred
in other parts of the world it started
off a very very wrong okay so this is
like China five years ago as a China 20
years ago yeah very wrong there were a
few entrepreneurs who you know Kim went
back from here so they what they're
doing but they didn't quite understand
the local markets as well so it was hard
and then there are lots of companies
that set up going after you know really
small markets and go I need me see
financing you know it doesn't work yeah
and so lots of learnings it's gotten
really better in the last two years I
would say I think partly because the
international population experienced
international population of tech
executives have gone up significantly
the the unicorns have brought people in
but other folks understanding what's
going on in Southeast Asia have gone
they're both attorneys and and people
from elsewhere we've been doing this for
and coming here to talk about this for
about four years now yeah so I think
some folks through this kind of
connections have gone back a lot of the
CEOs of the bigger companies have been
recruiting out here yeah so people
understand know a little bit better
about the value creation that's
happening back there so just as a real
brief note monks Hill sponsors quarterly
programs called
SCA connect and they we've been
fortunate we've been honored to
cooperate in several of these and had
some of the portfolio companies and some
other companies from Southeast Asia
featured and they've been really
interesting evening programs so in the
kind of things that encourage
entrepreneurship is there's definitely
an uptick in venture capital what about
at the very early stage companies first
getting started before they're ready for
venture capitalists yeah when when I
think when grab-and-go Jack started
hitting the headlines some and then
tokopedia bucola Park and all those guys
in Indonesia there that's actually a lot
of wealth and Southeast Asia that's in
the conglomerates in the traditional and
businesses manufacturing extractive
industries a lot of the bigger families
took a bunch of cash and just put it
into the technical sector so literally
hundreds of millions of dollars went
into funding companies with like two
people one person now you're saying
family offices paying office okay and
this is a lot of the people who did kind
of old-style company development do have
these more or less family controlled
companies where the family
a lot of well and they do have kids that
come here
ya know what Tech is like yeah they are
taking that money and then investing
into the startups
so that paved the way for that Cambrian
explosion of really early-stage startup
ok that's where after that we stepped in
the series a you guys know coming in ok
so what about the incubator situation
there are there do you see a rise in
incubators and accelerators all kinds of
ways I'm not necessarily a big fan okay
you be it as creating startups but that
there's been a rise of all kinds of
venture builders incubators accelerators
I don't even know the difference between
some of this stuff but you know lots of
ways to get companies going you know and
what my personal belief is an
entrepreneur with high conviction
starting a company is the way you start
companies yeah whether it's an
accelerator or what have you it doesn't
really matter so long as that person is
passionate about creating a company yeah
so the capital thing really does come
back to the people oh I'm curious so I
think it was about 12 and 1/2 billion in
VC invested in Southeast Asia last year
of which 95 went into Indonesia either
directly or indirectly are you seeing
that as keeping up with the demand
because it really is a shark right yeah
you know this might sound strange but I
think some of its going to the wrong
place okay
there is a lot of global risk capital
and you see it in uber etc that even in
DT which we were series investors are
not months about the GS are there's a
lot of risk capital that seems to be
okay with being put into from my point
of view very high risk high valuation
situations
mm-hmm and Southeast Asia has
keep that so we've got a bunch of
companies at the high end that have
raised a lot of money and very high
valuations and and then the the smaller
one is actually a very good deal
yeah so for the series II guys that's
great yeah okay we will take the risk in
at the low level and suddenly we got in
real-time variations on top good is the
top end valuations are those going up
because of the mega deals or is
absolutely more that than the public
market then yes no no public markets
okay not yet not yet okay so there are a
few IPOs but the majority so in the mega
deal world it really looks like China
influence versus American influence you
know all trying to make sure that they
invest in in the winning football team
or whatever yes are you do you see
different kind of patterns of investment
between like detuning and and so forth
not really I mean it all gets traced
back to division Softbank vision fund
okay yeah yeah okay so you're either in
the you know in that stable of watch
companies or you're not and so for the
series a investor that basically means a
good increase in valuation yeah but
doesn't mean you have to think longer to
hold the investor so I I don't know if
the kind of what I call negative cross
margins blitzscaling
stuff that's happening will last for
long okay this is if it looks like a
bubble that might be a problem okay so
if I sell you a dollar for dollar bill
for 80 cents
yeah how fast with my business grow
pretty fast as I can get there you
control a lot so those that way that the
problem is we've had these kinds of
business models I know I've been
involved in some of them control huge
right
and some of them actually end up being
defensible but some of them I don't know
maybe won't yeah yeah so right now one
of the areas that you really think are
really promising as opposed to
overvalued well the good news are the
smaller guys is hopefully at some point
become overbearing but but the point is
as long as you can get out yeah well
actually it doesn't matter okay
but the the the base principle you know
this is where I've being a VC I get a
little bit confused maybe you know my
traditional with the traditional way I
look at my face is by creating value I
make money you know right these days you
can't just by having money I can't make
more money by pumping it up right so
what do I do
so Mozilla is just decided which is
going to focus on free English value
right if you're techni fiying if you if
you if your company is two times three
times four times the productivity of the
industry it doesn't matter if there's a
recession you're still gonna make money
and that's a very good point so so we
focus on doing that and also up or down
long term will be okay so I guess if we
look at your portfolio then we see
companies and areas that you think are
like that they're increasing the
efficiency you had mentioned this had a
headhunting firm right are there other
kind of areas of the portfolio you know
cellular the vegetable seller we have a
health care services company that
connects all kinds of healthcare
services we have a app that teaches you
standard American English folk Winston
American rubbish from Stanford GSB yeah
founder it's probably more you know we
have a several lending
company sweater means for individuals
well so kind of to end the formal part
of this I sort of want to go on and ask
you what are the sort of ways in which
Silicon Valley now is participating in
Southeast Asia or vice versa and also
what kind of recommendations you would
have but right now you know there are
several venture capital firms that are
based here and there are also several
companies that are interested in
expanding from here but do you see a
real uptick in the kind of cross-border
activity already or is it still waiting
to happen
yeah it's the way the only Silicon
Valley company that's really present in
Southeast Asia is at Sequoia Sequoia
India actually yeah so the rest of them
I don't think have done any duce okay
okay there are probably three Chinese
species that have opened up shop and in
Singapore mmm just so by and large
Southeast Asia is still handle myself
East Asian pcs so that's on the
investment side but what about you know
companies like AWS or you know so so if
if you look at the rise in revenues in
the AWS yeah yes you know keeps going
well right and one of the drivers is
startups right startups are small but
within four years they're you know let
out sometimes yeah
so AWS is actually a partner of ours oh
okay they sponsor a lot of startup
activities because they know this is
their future mega customers yeah no and
it's already true today and with with
some of the companies okay
so so AWS for sure I think Google has
announced they're gonna go local for the
data of what do you call rest where the
data has to be in the country okay
you're right the residency rules right
so Google is opening up their cloud in
Jakarta yeah Indonesia definitely
requires all financial data and most
personal data to be kept inside the
country
yep stored in a data center there so you
know the big players are already there
okay Facebook I think I forget which
country but yeah now I think yeah
Facebook probably has the largest da um
au ratio which means the most engaged
users so in that regard I'm kind of
curious how Southeast Asia views Fang
right Facebook Amazon Netflix and Google
have they are they taking over the
Southeast Asia markets or are they kind
of game players in this in India you
hear people complaining about Fang being
too much having too much control yeah I
don't think they're as focus Facebook
and Google are more focused in Southeast
Asia Netflix is opening up Amazon I
don't think it's focused at all in
Southeast Asia
yeah okay just happens people use AWS
yeah it's like for me yeah which is a
very different yeah yeah so how do you
look at this stuff
well this is I guess it's different from
China in a certain way in China you know
Facebook Google they're all blocked
right and Amazon's not and Netflix has
not gone there I think but I'm not sure
if it would be blocked I haven't
right but so the two main players Google
and Facebook are just not in the picture
yeah the biggest difference it does in
Southeast Asia to have those two groups
on there is that there's certain
businesses you just don't go into you
don't go in the search business you
don't go into the you know social
networking business actually it doesn't
stop people from trying yeah but it's
hard to build big businesses there but
conversely you do have Alibaba and you
know the ten cent WeChat segment is
really trying to move into Southeast
Asia I think ah this might sound strange
but I don't think that Chinese companies
really care that much of uh Southeast
Asia
okay I think if you've got a giant
domestic market to develop okay
yeah so I was talking to my friends last
year when I was back in Beijing you know
all the BT generals they're all fighting
battles in China they're not really that
concern of what's outside yes there's a
billion here a billion there being
invested in Southeast Asia from these
groups yeah but that's okay so kind of
to go back to what I was saying
what should Silicon Valley entrepreneurs
as well as investors how should they be
looking at Southeast Asia when does it
become relevant to them yeah this is not
easy because a lot of value creation is
being done on the ground by
understanding how things work on the
ground so if you have a business here
how relevant is is it to Southeast Asia
you know I don't know because if you're
not okay if you have a horizontal piece
of technology maybe someone like me aw
this know maybe someone couldn't use you
but if you are vertical let's say you're
a finance company like a firm like that
right how relevant is Southeast Asia
well it's totally different it's an
emerging market you probably you look
probably too busy going after your
domestic market you worry about what's
going on mm-hmm
but if you are big you feel like Google
Facebook you've gotta engage because
that's where the you know 650 million
people growing steadily
you got it so let's say you've got a
data analytics firm that would really
help a retailer understand how to get
more revenue per customer
is that something that you think if you
are going to try to take that to
Southeast Asia what would you do it's a
good one I would make sure it works here
and you've got good you know it's
interesting some of the Chinese
companies we see out in Southeast Asia
did make in China and so they thought it
might be easier in Southeast Asia Wow
sometimes they work sometimes it does
the so and and the the good news is the
retail companies are big enough they're
in the billions of dollars of valuations
you know hundreds of millions in revenue
you know that they will pay for these
things it helps them improve their yeah
the margins you know so you can have
these conversations with these companies
okay are there any kind of external
factors like political instability or
concern about American policy that are
affecting the markets their political
instability we just had a riot in
Jakarta I mean the election results were
announced people didn't like Italy right
so cause a burn that's emerging markets
but I expect some of that in terms of
American politics I think most folks
it's obvious is you look at it as just a
big blur if things are happening but
really
the fact that's that much it might be
fun to watch the happenings but okay and
in fact I think net of it all so easy my
benefit because it'll drive you know a
set of the trade going between China and
the US yeah my driving to Southeast Asia
but that's not the tech sector right
more than traditional economy yeah yeah
but on the other hand you do have a lot
of investment restrictions you have a
lot of concern about security and IP
yeah how the Southeast Asia regarded and
in that aspect it's a whole spectrum
right you got Singapore wares and
intellectual property how dare of law
etc and and other places might not be as
strong but you know you know if you look
at the types of businesses who are
building they're they're not tech tech
companies per se there are logistics
companies they are you know real estate
brokerages you know etc so the IP itself
is not that important
yeah they protect the IP by not exposing
it so knowledge of the local system in
broad sense is really the most critical
matter this you could argue that's the
IP ya operate in Jakarta or Bangkok etc
okay so so what we think of as
intellectual property is very here is
very different over there yeah okay
I think now is a good point to open the
floor to questions from the audience
Rajesh you first I saw your hand first
so you say
but by me not me important I mean yes
you can protect IP differently by not
exposing it to the wall all right so the
headhunting company I mentioned the way
they mesh on employers to engineers they
don't have to show the world why do this
they just need to do it and benefit from
the results of doing that so in fact I
can pick up on what Rajesh was saying I
think that you know if you grow up to a
certain point knowledge of the local
conditions and local relationships is a
barrier to entry yes but if you're
trying to expand into a ten billion
dollar a year company you need other
mechanisms besides that how do companies
expand if you know it's really not so
much who's got the best fancy new
technology yeah it's not I mean if you
if you have a user wolf grab and and
uber right we had grandma uber in
Southeast Asia for the longest time
right and the day they shut down ooh BRR
a lot of us were very unhappy sorry
Anthony but it needs to see you off a
grab but uber is a superior application
to grant right and but life goes on you
still need that car so you still use the
graphic and it's improving all the time
so I and I think goober got 27 and a
half percent of grab that's not bad for
the media's and they got a chunk oh yeah
yeah yeah I don't know if I answered
your question but it's
[Music]
with scaling kind of stop yeah I
actually don't know what to say to that
because if you are traditional business
builder you look at this stuff and you
go I'm not sure what's going on right
it's like last year with the I CEOs and
you know what is going on you have no
idea there's greed and fear right so I I
don't have a good answer for you in
terms of the negative but scaling
negative cross margin blitz caylor's it
happens and it's how people buy market
share we actually don't know if this
experiment is going to work out okay in
the long run right just a few people
with lots of control lots of money let's
try this
across the region because I think W
sorry one more moment sorry
logistics overheads and so on because
actually there's not the the value is
not created a lot by things going across
boundaries is within the countries
within the cities as an observer I'd
point out that the role of government is
not very visible yeah
this is you know the international
organizations certainly have an impact
like you say but people on the you know
day to day situation don't really notice
yeah WTO is this about enter sort of
inter-country tree yeah most of them but
the the value creation is not trading
the tech companies are not rated yeah
it's evaluation within Ho Chi Minh City
in faggins is not even throughout the
country as a city capital promise
borders
yeah so that's the ASEAN thing right the
last forty years we've been doing that
not in tech businesses right one of the
biggest telco owners in the Philippines
is in the nation they've been doing this
all along
so thank you I was gonna say technique
but I don't think was a very conscious
effort is a lot of the entrepreneurs
over there studied here right summit
Stanford but other schools here and they
meet friends for some reason nice young
kids do hang up together here so they
would know Indonesia
No Malaysian they don't know a Filipino
and when they go back and they just call
their friends and go hey you want to do
this start up with me and that's how it
happens a lot of times sometimes it's
not like close friends sometimes it's
just school mates etc or ex McKinsey
folks you know but it happens like that
and so so my advice if you want to go do
a start-up there know a lot of people
from different countries yeah billion a
no but that's not any different from
when we start up here and that's
actually a good characteristic of here
you can know people from a lot of
different countries here yeah other
questions thank you other questions you
know that in terms of the FinTech
which is one of the focus and I guess
you're you are focusing on
so in Southeast Asia many of the country
makes have very popular about so that
people pee in the pavement for many
years you know so what do you think will
be the next possible opportunities for
the fin type in our skin what was C
what's the next opportunity for fin tech
entrepreneurs the Southeast Asia imagine
so so lending is big I'm not sure if you
said lending is it's one of these areas
but that lending is big but there are
the areas too
I would be a little bit more careful
about insurance because at four thousand
GDP per capita not a lot of people pay
attention to insurance right but as it
grows then it gets interesting
it's like China right eight nine
thousand insurance is a lot of startups
focus on credit and credit awareness and
ability to lend even if it's not lending
itself we've got a company called c88 it
matches you to lend
right it understands your credit profile
and the credit requirements of lenders
and mattress.you that so I would say you
know last year to give you a scale an
idea of scale here last year there were
about 200 apps that was shut down
lending apps that was shut down in
Indonesia because they weren't licensed
so that's just scale did they know they
should have been licensed for today okay
this is interesting and if I can kind of
follow up on that a little bit in
FinTech what you have is really major
industry transformation where the
incumbent banks are either partnering
with new kinds of in-between companies
that really have the mobile app defined
they know how to get to they know how to
get to the customers and they are able
to open up new markets for the banks
yeah so who has the power relationship
and there is a really interesting
question yeah it used to be the banks
always did but now there's almost like
they're becoming suppliers and it's
these app providers who have the real
power in terms of knowing the customers
yeah those are you mean to be mean that
gochang and grab assuming they succeed
will healthily be in finance companies
yeah go ahead
example to what extent are there
commonalities in the city environment
for those applications to develop and
flourish relative to the United States
where you've seen the very robust
development no it's cabbage and Lending
Club and a slightly different but but in
Southeast Asia you know I had a company
from the valley going hey I would like
to come out there and see if we can we
can do some lending can you tell me
about the credit credit agencies or the
credit score agencies right there are
not so how do you know if someone's
credit worthy you gotta go figure it out
right so that's the hard part
but this is a big data problem this is a
problem that tech can solve right and
that's why we're doing you know in part
technology's boys train yeah not as much
these days even if folks use blockchain
they don't talk about it as much so does
that okay okay yeah my Amazon your thing
about ecommerce or even retail
billion-dollar ecommerce companies in
Southeast Asia so I would not invest in
e-commerce in Southeast Asia at this
point
are you talking about investing in
companies they are worth a billion and
more are you talking about that will be
worth more a strategy that you okay so
we're series a but it's similar to see
we go after the technification strategy
right the BOC about these out say about
80 to 90 percent of our deals are about
some entrepreneur that is competently
pursuing a vertical right whether it's
head hunting of food or some some
something right and then we have a few
horizontal place okay I think that's a
simple way to detect the Southeast Asian
market and I also you know I really like
what you said earlier about creating
value right you look for a company where
your infusion of capital can help create
value and not just you know as a passive
all the speculation activity actually
this is a very similar problem to when I
was in China the problem is not that we
got so many verticals which one do we go
after the problem is where the competent
entrepreneurs who can actually win in a
vertical right they're not enough of
them right so our hardest task is to
find these entrepreneurs well you know
all out gonna win in a particular
vertical that's our hardest job
like that this is not any different from
here right it's just people who
absolutely they have to win and they
know they're making a huge difference by
winning the charismatic in your own way
you know think can I ask you a kind of a
personal question that regard so you
were a serial entrepreneur how much do
you think that that experience was
really a critical part of being able to
become a good investor I'm not sure
about that but it gives me a lot more
credibility when I speak up in the board
very different yeah okay so so we
require our partners to have startup
experience because they're gonna sit on
a board we take boards yeah so they're
gonna sit on the board and talk to the
entrepreneurs about what they think yeah
it's really hard to have someone who's
never built a company tell someone who
is in the process of building a huge
company you know or maybe even suggest
no and not have that CEO question you
know you know where's your thinking
coming right so it's a lot easier if you
build a few companies to say hey look
consider this
I never tells you what to do no telling
what I would do right sometimes
sometimes I just tell them what happened
yeah so I think it helps in that in that
regard
as a result of that I think the
entrepreneurs are more willing to spend
time with me to consider my offer
mm-hmm and that helps competitively and
that also involves the value creation
really partnering with months old gifts
for him yeah
regulatory role of God on the one hand
in shutting down unlicensed companies
and the other in acquiring the
multinationals down a local face
but do you see any government role in
entrepreneurial policy either as funding
venture capital or in other ways I think
that the government's could do a lot to
facilitate entrepreneurship a few but I
realize it's politically difficult
because I've I've talked to the Thai
government obviously Singapore
government
Taiwanese government etc you know what
one of the things we need to do is allow
more porous movement of talent right but
most countries want to control that they
don't want anyone to build come into the
country and start working flow of
capital is also another issue but that
has been sort of taken care of by the
corporate structure right so it's not as
big a problem as before some of the
protectionist policies make it more
difficult for the FBI to come in if you
make ecommerce a protected domain for
example and you need to be you know 75
or 51% owned by in the nations it's a
lot harder to build you know ecommerce
companies in Asia now the older
companies have all been what he called
it you could be hundred percent owned by
foreign entities but now no longer so
with regard to a government investment
in entrepreneurship you know these kind
of programs where we want to create a
thousand startups or whatever one kind
of sense I have is that governments when
they get into that are trying to divide
that to broadcast the money to benefit
large groups of people more or less
equally and that's exactly the wrong
attitude to use with if you're trying to
invest in successful startups where you
really want to find the winners in a
particular vertical
selling shy it's a big issue of the
large state-owned firms being so closely
connected government rock you see any
movements along these lines in the
fairest of East Asia cookies I'll be
trying to follow simple strategies I
don't see anything
it won't be intentional about how to
work with state-owned companies to help
entrepreneurship and frankly it doesn't
matter
go ahead in terms of launches somebody
could copy about designing this wiki was
launched and gave us a copy
do you see companies like that emerging
now in Southeast Asia again or what is
your approach do you steal invest in
those companies the source of the copies
are actually closer to China then then
the u.s. know right like go food was a
llama LME right as opposed to deliver so
so I think we look to China more for
models simply because the economic
situation is very similar China went
from the last ten years fifteen years
about four thousand GDP to about eight
nine thousand GDP right we're at 4,000
in Southeast Asia so the models make a
lot more sense and that the only problem
is the the language very not as many
people understand what's going on in
China okay
other questions
second question so I saw you on the
bottom of my way so I just saw oh yeah
what do you think what the social media
and shot videos that's are those things
well be very popular in South Asia and
the ethical legal life people life is
affiliated with why I was spun out in
one way and it's I think spinning back
in those of us who may not know bigger
like what how would you explain what
they're doing real quick oh man that's
hard people are watching other people do
things and they spend millions of
dollars in activities around that and
this is huge and try now you you have a
sense of it here with let me ask it the
other way who's heard of tick tock
that's what big old life is you know you
watch other people do things and and big
old life is life so you actually see
them live
doing stuff the technology is incredible
right I come from a Chinese thumb our
family has been musically and yeah so we
have a competitor that so whether those
social media's opportunities still good
opportunities for research so many of
the Chinese funds they think that's the
social medias are already you know maybe
maybe past their time
yes male them still think that's the
truth and the UN something well Bieber
being so
I don't focus as much on social media
because it is a bit Southeast Asia is a
bit too open the market for company like
YY for example to come in flooded with
investments and get lots of installs and
start getting a huge install fees right
so it the capital efficiency of the
ability to raise larger amounts of money
from elsewhere like here in China is is
it's much more possible to do that right
so if I were to start a Asian Southeast
Asian social media phone I cannot raise
as much money to compete with these
other guys right so I just stay out of
that business right so can a Chinese
company build a big business and
Southeast Asia doing the social media
yes this already happen okay thank you
one more question
go ahead pure investment do you only
invest in companies that want to set up
shop in Southeast Asia with the second
piece as a possible mandate right and we
ended up doing almost nothing in that
area
simply because the the series ain't
deals and Saudis leaders it just went
through the roof last year we saw 1,300
deals in Southeast Asia
now that's deal you listen this is not
out of the number this is not the number
of proposals you or you know whatever
request that you receive yeah yeah yeah
yeah but but some of the folks started
companies here and then they move back
right there's a bunch of Southeast Asian
sometimes ice okay go ahead but just
something balling okay so what if you're
doing a company here but your user base
in Southeast Asia is growing is it
cannot would you can consider that as
well I know like the Deaf work consider
but if we got no value acting you then
you know we probably won't invest but if
you aren't selling yeah then we can okay
so as I said we've got some refreshments
outside we'd like to encourage everybody
to stay around and network and and get
to meet ping and talk with each other I
want to thank everybody for your
participation in the sessions in the
series if this is you know not your
first time here welcome everybody we
will start again in fall quarter with a
series of similar programs but about
edge computing especially the more
recent developments and related to edge
computing like IOT systems in Asia and
then will repeat our entrepreneurship in
Asia seminar next a seminars next spring
so if you would first please join me in
thanking ping for group
[Applause]